well tonight new officers are joining
the ranks of metro 37 police recruits
graduated sally jaramillo attended the
event at the las vegas convention center
she's live in our newsroom with a look
at some of the new faces who are ready
to protect and serve sally today's
graduating class 32 men and five women
many coming from different parts of the
world aruba brazil germany and the
philippines these new police officers
hope to encourage more people to join
law enforcement
honestly i never wanted to do this
officer brianna jarraza was born and
raised in las vegas she says her idea of
becoming a police officer arose from an
event that we will never forget the
october one shooting when i was there
under a bleacher talking to my dad
it just like
clicked gerason knew she wanted to help
people in her community while she became
an emt after that event there was more
she needed to do i
just hope to make an impact bigger than
my size especially after route 91
this
city became so much stronger after that
and i think
we still need us to hold it together the
recruitment process for her was smooth
and stress-free she encourages more
women to join the academy as she says
they have great intuition are caring and
can make a huge impact in our society if
you have something like in here
try it
[Applause]
darrasso adds there's always a need for
officers as metro continues to recruit
across the nation we posted that
information on that process on our
website eightnewsnow.com sally caramillo
live local now